I started to think of doing mathematics in
the one year before last of high school.
So I was already 15 or something when I realized
that I was enjoying solving problems that
were resisting, that were a little harder
than usual.
I had to think and absorb myself in them and
forget about everything else and come back
with a solution.
One time I found a solution that was rather
creative.
I remember the teacher was surprised when
I presented my solution, and I think this
is when it really clicked for me that I would
like to try to do research in math, just because
I was enjoying the process.
Indeed I don't see myself as a prodigy or
a genius at all.
There are geniuses out there, but the geniuses
are the exception rather than the norm — even
within the profession.
Genius is kind of like a God-given thing,
right.
You have it or you don't have it.
I prefer to think of ability or talent, which
is something that can be cultivated and built
up with hard work.
I think certainly you don't have to be a genius
to become a mathematician and to do interesting
mathematics.
It's more a question of ability and having
the taste and the stamina to do it.
Being wiling to put in the hard work and enjoying
the process of the research.
Having the right frame of mind, the right
mindset for it.